Oh
[Music]
the powerhouse singers like Cody Lee
brought their a-game to the America's
Got Talent finale Tuesday night did you
feel like a rock star I feel like a rock
star the 23 year old singer who's blind
and autistic delivered his most stunning
performance yet Cody's vocals left judge
Simon Cowell nearly speechless that was
as good as I've ever heard I said to him
afterwards how do you manage to do that
extra lift in the song every time you've
just got this unbelievable ability to
know when to turn it on I loved it when
you did good
I loved performing on America's Got
Talent
would it mean to see him up there and
just shine so bright he keeps notching
it up you know he keeps going better and
better and better another musician that
earned rave reviews violinist Tyler
Butler Figueroa who's a cancer survivor
hence his empowering song choice a
Destiny's Child classic
[Music]
and how's this for an epic surprise
fiance personally cleared that's all she
likes it I guess I performed it and I
hope she like are you hoping that one
day maybe she'll take you out on tour
comedian Ryan me Miller kept the crowd
laughing he especially impressed judge
Gabrielle Union I have a production
company I am making movies and I want
you to be a star in one of my movies I
think I got a movie deal Gabrielle I
love her she's been nothing too sweet to
me but if she tries to back out it's a
verbal contract it is on television
people solid hate that exists forever is
there a project or role you have in mind
for Ryan you said you had you'll hire
literally pitching stuff like back in my
kit back in my dressing room there are
so many things he can do I kind of I'm
hoping that he plays a guy who wins the
competition and then loses himself
becomes a little full of himself becomes
a womanizer and then his journey is one
of getting back to is true in history so
the Detroit youth choir and love you
youth choir Iman Misha and voices of
service all sang their hearts out while
dancers in light balance brought it and
the unbeatable delivered their most
insane and gravity-defying routine yet
[Music]
[Applause]
are you guys still hype yes we are
feeling amazing like we receive the
audience love and they voted for us and
Jair we performed in the finals and yes
we already happy about it there's a
million dollars in a Las Vegas residency
up for grabs who will take it find out
Wednesday when America's Got Talent
announces the scene at 14 winner
[Music]